kovid's recent surge in india has been
devastating the virus has caused at
least 29 million infections
and 363 000 deaths most of them
since the middle of april while new
cases are declining the nation of more
than one billion people continues to
struggle
with the societal effects of the virus
in one major city an
army of volunteers is trying to deliver
help and hope
all on three wheels chris livesay has
the story
from new delhi good morning they're
called
auto rickshaws and they typify india's
chaotic streets
now as the country's pandemic rages
they're also typifying efforts
to save lives
one rushes a 60 year old patient to the
hospital
another zooms food to victims and their
families
it's a lot to ask of these modest
three-wheeled taxis
but as india reels in a catastrophic
second wave of covet
heroes have emerged in unlikely shapes
and sizes
new delhi is choking under covid says
cabbie raj kumar
i'm providing this ambulance service to
help the public if everyone stayed home
because they were scared
then who's going to help those in need
other rickshaw drivers organize here
at the gurudwara bangla sahib a sikh
temple
where cooks prepare 35 000 hot meals
every day zipping them out to the poor
among those who have been hit hardest by
this pandemic
this country is so huge and this virus
is so punishing we actually have no idea
how many people are sick
or dead but what we do know is food
deliveries like these
are one thing helping keep them alive
once they arrive
drivers descend by foot into some of the
poorest neighborhoods in new delhi
where kovid plus hunger is a lethal
combination
says local resident rita malhotra
there's no work amid the lockdown and
the pandemic if it weren't for this food
people here could starve even many of
these volunteers are out of a job
gangadeep singh worked as a school bus
driver until a city-wide lockdown
closed all the schools
now i have a lot of free time he says so
i thought it was a good idea to use it
to help save the lives of covet patients
my neighbors
now we know kovit's been killing indians
in record numbers but it's also been
killing
the economy and in a country where
millions upon millions live below the
poverty line
these food deliveries are nothing short
of a life saver
for cbs this morning saturday chris
livesay new delhi
creativity continues for people within
the pandemic and trying to battle in any
way they can
you make do i mean you find a way
important to do